my man CD lamb set two Cowboys franchise
records in the game he passed Michael
Irving for the most catches and the most
receiving yards in the season he was
selected for the drug test but it
doesn't even matter we know he's clean
that CD M lamb the best receiver in NFL
not top five not top three he's top two
not two and I think he's putting on the
show and if it wasn't for them that
little drought period that he before he
had to show that he's always open he
arguably would have broke the record
uh I don't care what nobody say CD's a a
boss he's a number one receiver um and
you know if it wasn't for Christian
McCaffrey's year that he's having um
who's arguably going up for MVP right
now he going back and forth but I think
Lamar just solidified himself as MVP he
probably should be offensive player of
the year um him and Christian Tyreek is
having uh some of the best seasons that
you know anyone could ever see in the
NFL um one of the three best weapons um
bro it it's just been off the chain for
the um d three this year but uh you know
CD's arguably right there he has one
more game Christian sitting out to try
to go claim that um and let's see how he
does in that standpoint but CD lamb
congratulations brother you are truly
shown why you're the number one a lot of
people a lot of naysayers there was a
lot of naysayers I remember Richard
Sherman early in the year said he wasn't
even a top five receiver
whatever A lot of people say he couldn't
be a number one when Amar Cooper was
gone um but CD still here he just
continuously to get better continuously
just keep proving people wrong and he's
having a year of his life and he's gonna
have a big big payday coming soon so uh
the drip God is going to be shining
shining bling bling again real real
soon